we're on problem number seven if the
average of X and 3x is 12 what is the
value of x so the average of X plus 3x
I'm averaging two numbers so divided by
two and that's going to be equal to 12
so we just solve for this multiply both
sides equation by 2 and you get right
two x times two this cancels with this
you get X plus 3x is equal to 24 and
what's X plus 3x that's 4x right 4x is
equal to 24 X is equal to 6 and that's
choice C next problem problem 8 at Maple
Creek High School some members of the
Chess Club are also on the swim team and
no members of the swim team are 10th
graders which of the following must be
true
ok this this seems like it'll call for a
Venn diagram so let's say that that's
that represents the Chess Club Chess
Club and they say some members of the
Chess Club are on the swim team so some
members are on the swim team so let me
maybe I should do the swim team in light
blue so let's say the swim team that's a
swim team swim team and these are the
members right that that are in both
right here but then it tells us no
members of the swim team are 10th
graders no members of the swim team are
10th graders so if I draw another circle
for the 10th graders it can't intersect
with the swim team but it could
intersect with the chess team I don't
know I mean it could be like that that
could be 10th graders it could be like
that or it could it could be out here
someplace but we don't know it there
could be chess and 10th graders just not
the same people who are on the swim team
right so let's see choice a says no
members of the chat so which of the
following must be true no members of the
Chess Club or 10th graders no this is a
situation where you could have some
members of the Chess Club who aren't on
the swim team who could be 10th graders
be some members of the Chess Club are
10th graders well some members could be
but we don't know for sure this could be
10th grade we don't know that
this could be the 10th grade kind of set
or this could be the 10th grade there
might be no 10th graders in either the
chess team or the swim team we don't
know for sure and then choice choice II
some members of the Chess Club are not
10th graders this we know for sure how
do we know it for sure because these
kids these kids who are on both right
there in the Chess Club but they're also
in the swim team the fact that they're
in swim team we know that they can't be
10th graders right so this is some
members of the Chess Club
this little intersection here that are
not 10th graders so choice C is the
correct choice next problem if 3 X 3 X
plus N is equal to X plus 1 what is n in
terms of X we essentially just solve for
n let's subtract 3x from both sides you
get n is equal to what's X minus 3x it's
minus 2 x and then plus 1 and then we're
done and that choice isn't there but if
you just switch these two terms you just
get 1 that equals 1 minus 2x and that's
choice D pretty quick problem for action
especially for one that's the ninth
problem they don't look a little harder
by this point problem 10 if K is a
positive integer let K be defined as a
as a set of all multiples of K so k with
a square around it is equal to the set
of multiples of K all of the numbers in
which of the following sets are also in
all three of the set ok all of the
numbers in which of the following sets
are also in all three of the sets of 2 3
& 5 okay so what they're saying is you
know 2 3 2 3 5 2 3 5 right this donates
all the multiples of 2 all multiples of
2
this is all multiples of three this is
all multiples of five so what they're
essentially saying is let's find a
number where all of its multiples all of
this numbers multiples are also going to
be multiples of each of these right so
it has to be a multiple so every number
that it that this whatever this mystery
number is let's call it X every multiple
of X has to be multiple of two three and
five right well the simple way is if X
is a multiple of two three and five then
every multiple of X can be multiple of
two three and five so it's 2 times 3
times 5 it's 2 times 3 times 5 that's 6
times 5 that's 30 so 30 30 is a multiple
of all of them so any multiple 30 will
be a multiple of all of these we look at
the choices we don't see 30 right but do
we see any other number that is a
multiple of 2 3 & 5
well sure 60 is right we just multiply
by 2 again but 60 is still a multiple of
2 3 & 5 if you do two-four-six-eight all
the way you get 60 if you add 3 9 12 15
all the way you'd get 260 you go 5 10 15
20 25 you get to 60 so 60 is a multiple
of all of them so if you what we're
saying is so what's the set of all the
multiples of 60 it's 60 120 180 180 240
etc right and all of these numbers are
multiples are in each of these sets
right because all of these numbers are
multiples of 2 3 & 5 so our answer is 16
if you look at the other choices some of
them are divisible by 5 somewhere to
live about 2 or 3 somewhere 3 & 5 but
none of them are divisible by 2 3 & 5
only 60 is next problem
the problem was a little hard to read
initially though that's why they confuse
you okay so let's see we have so I'm
gonna go from A to D I should draw on
all the lines first draw the lines like
hexagon kind of top the outside of the
hexagon they're a b c d e f and then
this is origin and the figure above ad
is equal to b e ad is equal to b e i
don't know they don't saw something I'm
hallucinating and I figure about a DBE
and C F intersect at point O
ok the intersect here at the origin if
the measure of a o be a o be the measure
of that is 80 degrees and C F bisects Bo
d c-- f bisects d OD so it bisects this
larger angle right CF bisects B OD that
angle so that tells us that this angle
has to be equal to this angle that's the
definition of bisecting an angle you're
splitting this larger angle in half so
these doing angles have to be equally to
each other so what is the measure of e o
f e o f okay so we want to figure out
this angle well this angle is opposite
to this angle so they're going to be
equal so if we can figure out this angle
we're done so let's call this angle X if
that angles X this angle is also X right
and this X this X and this 80 degrees
they're all supplementary right because
they all go halfway around the circle so
X plus X plus 80 it's going to be equal
to 180 degrees 2x plus 80 is equal to
180 2x is equal to 100 X is equal to 50
and as we said before if X is equal to
50 the angle e Oh F which you're trying
to figure out is opposite to it so it's
going to be equal
this is also gonna be fifty degrees and
that's choice B next problem not FF time
for this but I'll try problem 12 K is a
positive integer what is the least value
of K for which square root of five times
okay so what is the least value of K for
which five K over three is an integer so
this has to be a whole number right so
essentially if we want to find the least
value of K we essentially want to say
well what's the least integer that this
could be well and they're telling us
that K is a positive integer so first of
all it in order for the square root to
be to be an integer this whole thing has
to be has to be an integer right so okay
let's see K has to be a multiple of
three in order for this expression to be
an integer K has to be multiple three if
K is 3 we get square root of 15 over 3
well that doesn't work right okay if K
is 3 we just get 5 in there actually let
me continue this into the next problem
cuz I don't want to rush this I'll see
in the next video